IT JUSS TESTIMONY  W
ADH FAST ANDFURIOUN SPEAKING,
SAYINGS OF
UKRAINER
OF THIS ARE NOF
THEM  RF RAINE WERE, HERE'S HIS
THRES OF THEEFERENFRKING, NOT O
PLEASED .
I THINK THE ELECTI OBSERVERS
HIS ASL.NOES
SOMEIN
ITHE
ITE COURSE THIS N'FIC
ANS. T A
AGAI YT IT'S JUSBELIEVAB
ION
DOO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE VOTED.
BALLOT AT JE QUESTIONT TO CEDEM
S
AND THY OF IT IS
FORBES CITES A SOURCE WITHIN THE
LEFTA SINCE N RATION
ANNOD
MOZATION.
YOU CAN HEARRAHEATTLEFIELDNING O
STATE TV
E ILNING
G?T ANYTHINGROTECTED EN WIL ARR?
>> JUST THACCATO OF THE
WILL THIS?A SEA CHANGE FORSIAN
VISION.
HILE, TONIGHT, THE STP
THE LIADCAST BING UP THAT SAID
AR.SHE'S PE "OUTFRONT."
AN THESE IMAGES, THEREIS WITH MS
N' S FLED HOUSET TILL ON BODYSAV
THEY'LL STOPAL
CHILDREN WHO DIEFAKES AND THEY
PROSIN FNG THE
FRED PLEITGEN  LIVE
TOE INV T.
EY'RE  K TO
IL.
NOTARF RUSSIA
>> Reporter: YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE THOSE STRIKES THAT
PPKYIV, WHICH WERE AMIKAZON THA
WERE GIVEN TO
THE RUSSIANSY THE IRANIANS, THA
GNCAUSE A
WOULD'VE USED UI MISSIOR
SOMETHING ELSE TO HITARGTH'RE RO
THEY CAU DE  OIDERAIL WHAT THE
AND ESSENTIALLTHLY
REMARKABLE THING ABOUT THENCES E
TH VER AT THE MOMENTTH
T THEY WERE AB TO THE UKRAINIAN
WELL.CK SOME OF THESE VILLAGESES
BUT ALSO IN THE EAST WHERE
UKRAINIANS HAVSO GONE WELL YONDH
REALLYATOWN THAT THEY  JUPLE OF
HOWEVER, IS THAT THE FIGHTINT E
THERE CONTINUES E VERY
FURIOUS AS WELL.
KYIV SS O SHOWS ITS
NG IN THE EAST
OF THE COUNTRY UNDER HEAVY FIRE.
E HE STRATEGICALLY IMPORTANT TOS
AREAS  HAD BEE, ONE OF THE
RUSSIACO.
RESIDENTS GREETING THE TROOPS AS
THEYEP.
UKE'S MILIS
WELL WHEREV CLAIMS RA'FENSIVONIN
ME AREAS.
[ SOUND OF GUNFIRE ]
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY RELEASED
THIS VIDEO PURPORTING W
ITN A MAJOR FIRE FIG
INION.
AL SINCE THE RENIS
WEEK ALONEE'S PRESIDENT
SA.
ALL S IADENT THIS MORNG TO N THO
FOEVS
HIS FORCES AREY
LOSING GROUND S N BRUSHING OFF
CONCER
CERTAIN TERRITORIES WILL BE  SA.
ILO CONFER
THERE THAT WISHES
TO LIVE TOGETHER WIT
HAVOC INY REGIONS ES TLE
UKRAINE.
THIS IS THE SOUND OFONES HITNG
CAPITAL.
UKRAINSAEVERAL
IRANIAN-LI DRONE N IN A
VIDEO HITMOINAUNGO SEILDINGS A.
THERE WAS A ROARING NOISE, PIERH
H
ANKY WILL CONTINUE NT ADVANCES,O
TOSSWARD IS QUEST PEL RUSSIATROF
WHEN THE UKRAINIANS SAY THTHATO.
BUNT T
TIONINFO
THAT'S THEAT WE'RE
AND IT IS  SOMETHING THAT RU
IS FUNDAMENTAL.EE
THOSE PROGRAOR ALM
ENTIRE TIMAT THIS WAR HAS BEEN U
REALLY THAT IS CHANGING.
R THE CHANGE ITO
AND ONE OF THE THING WE
ARE HEARING FROM THALIN-CONTLLSY
SAY THOSHAT ARE BEING